foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
Monday in America
another mass shooting
former president calling for World War
over the Easter break
Clarence Thomas is a Nazi sympathizer
Republicans want to strip the rights
away from women to take a pill
let's see what else is there is there
anything else is there anything else
that we could uh talk
oh boy
happy Easter weekend happy Easter Monday
I guess you should say Jesus Christ
I was prepared to talk about World War
III this morning and
um there is a lot of news out of
Louisville it seems as if um four
victims have been shot and killed looks
like six have been injured the shooter
has been killed also it doesn't appear
to be a bank robbery it was at a bank
in Louisville Kentucky the governor came
on the scene almost immediately because
he actually Banks there the governor
banks at this Bank knows the people
inside the bank
it appears that it's a disgruntled
employee with a long rifle hmm
it's almost like we've seen this before
where have we seen is this like America
is this what this is do something you
[__] pieces of [__] [__] your
thoughts and prayers stick your thoughts
and prayers straight up your [__] ass
do something [__] do something
you know what I think Americans should
do
thought I was thinking this this morning
as I was listening to the news any
anyone anyone out there
at all that has these types of weapons
or any weapons at all I don't care if
their heirloom guns if they're hunting
rifles if they're handguns revolvers go
turn that [__] in [__] that [__] we
don't need these [__] the less
guns the more safety
and we start holding them accountable
that's enough of this [__] now we
watched last week as the Tennessee
legislator
expels two black members because they're
black and they're calling for gun reform
they didn't get rid of the white lady
I'm not blaming on her she just white
she just that's the privilege that she
has being born White
now in Louisville this morning
five people are dead
four victims and the [__] shooter
because why because why
why
because because you need to feel secure
about your masculinity about your white
gun culture that's right I did a video
and when I put up a [__] I put up a
[__] short about white gun culture
and people were all there on me you
[__] son of a [__] you race Trader
and blah blah blah on and on and on and
on and on and went
foreign
what else is it
you tell me
I mean if you got a problem you can
solve it with a gun in this goddamn
country
doesn't matter if it's a dispute at work
if you get mad at people at a school
doesn't matter if you have if you have
past grievances maybe maybe a spouse or
a loved one pisses you off you know what
maybe maybe you just have bigoted racist
views and you want to go to that side of
town and take it out on those people huh
maybe it's just maybe it's just you you
don't fit into society so the America
lets you have weapons weapons of war you
might as well use it to solve your
problem
all the while we have the the
ex-president and [__] [__] box
over Easter calling for World War III I
don't give a [__] whatever you want to
say you can knock me I don't care send
me a cease and desist Trump you're
calling for world war three you're
calling for it you want it this is what
you want
you're trying to stoke fear you're
trying to stoke violence
this is what you want because that's the
only thing that will save you I guess is
your thought process
[__] that guy [__] that guy Jack Smith
get get your [__] together friend it's
time hate Bonnie Willis get your [__]
[__] together it's time
let's show these [__] cultists to
their cult leader truly is
let's show them they're not gonna listen
Jesus Christ Republicans Republicans in
Tennessee
when people went to the Capitol to to do
anything it red flag background check
whatever just anything you can do
anything
just acknowledge that that you're part
of the [__] problem that you have
blood on your hands with the NRA just
something [__] something and they're
like oh yep those two black dudes we're
getting rid of them at a legislator yeah
that's what we're gonna do something
it's what happened
last week and now in Kentucky
Louisville
five more [__] dead
and Rand Paul Rand Paul has you [__]
you coward ass [__]
the senator from Kentucky
sends out his thoughts and payers this
morning on Twitter well thank God for
Rand Paul oh my God what would we do
without Rand Paul typing in his tots and
pears on Twitter what oh my God I'm sure
the family's in Louisville that lost
their loved ones today the friends of
all those people I'm sure they're just
ecstatic that Rand Paul has the guts and
the and the courage to type in thoughts
and prayers on Twitter [__] you Rand
Paul cut the [__] prayer boy you
[__]
honestly at this point anyone who's out
there giving their thoughts and prayers
we should put red flags on them that's
right you are [__] mentally unstable
if that's all you can muster up the
courage to say about what is happening
in America
with guns
you you have got some [__] problems
inside your skull if that's all the
courage you can muster up
is some invisible thoughts and some
worthless [__] prayers
kiss my [__] ass
oh here's another story
I almost missed this one but it seems
like there's top secret documents being
leaked through Mar-A-Lago I mean just
being leaked online that's what I meant
to say let me [__] break everyone
knows you those where those top secret
documents are coming from come on
on Russia come on everyone knows
that was part of the deal I'm sure
what do you want from me what do you
want from me oh that's a conspiracy
conspiracy theory really
you don't think it makes sense
usually what it is is what it is I mean
just like these shootings it's the
[__] guns it's not hard to see it's
not a conspiracy theory I'm not making
[__] up out of thin air it's the [__]
guns
top secret documents
being leaked that's gonna that's gonna
hurt our intelligence gathering from
Russia hmm
seems kind of suspicious don't you think
now's not the time to give up
at all
Now's the Time to really get [__]
pissed
I mean really
get [__] pissed there's a judge
here's another [__] story here's
another here's another Liberty being
trying to Stripped Away from Americans a
judge in Texas decides he's gonna do
whatever the [__] he wants don't matter
the law he don't give a [__] he's gonna
make sure women don't have access to a
pill
a pill that's been on the market for 20
years the safer and Tylenol
and he stays his own order
what does that tell you
what does it tell you
when a judge makes an order and then
stays their own order
and the one of the reasons why is
because out of Washington there was a
there was a contradictory a decision
from a federal judge which in my opinion
the FDA should tell that judge in Texas
to go [__] himself he made the decision
he stated Washington there's a federal
judge that said no you got to make this
available on the market they should make
it available on the market today it's
still on the market
[__] them [__] em
get it to the Supreme Court let them
make their decision and find out where
we need to fall in 2024 speaking of the
Supreme Court
oh my god did you hear did you hear that
Clarence Thomas is a Harlan Hitler
funded judge did you know that
funded judge that is how we're going to
say it here on the Tony Michaels podcast
I don't give a [__]
Harlan Hitler funded judge that's right
we got Harlan Hitler funded everything
there's probably more than Hitler funded
prosecutors there's probably Harlan
Hitler funded Senators there's probably
Harlan Hitler funded DA's who knows who
knows how how far and how deep this
Harlan Hitler funding goes
as you know Harlan Crowe is a
billionaire fascist out of Texas I'm not
just speaking out of turn here
[__] has a signed copy of
Minecon from Hitler
what the actual [__]
this is this is the same billionaire
that was giving millions of dollars
millions of dollars to Clarence Thomas
and his wife
and luxury gifts
nothing to see here and we find out that
Jeannie Thomas has not been reporting
income
and been transparent about the income
she's been getting they're Liars
can you imagine Clarence and Genie
Thomas are liars and cheats and frauds
oh my God
I don't know seems Seems like we got a
lot of issues to politicize and run on
in 2024 folks
if you're looking for [__] to get people
angry about and get them engaged there's
plenty just in this weekend just in this
last [__] weekend
they want they wanna they wanna
eradicate
our fellow our fellow Americans with
legislation
they they they want to take away women's
rights with state legislators and with
federal judges
they're not gonna do a God damn thing
about gun violence in this country and
weapons of war just being oh just all
over the streets anyone and everyone can
get one
damn the kids damn innocent civilians
damn damn them [__] them
they're not going to do what goddamn
well they will do something
they they will make sure to to expel
uppity black men in the Tennessee
legislator that's what they'll do about
it
they're taking away your parental
consent oh yeah [__] yeah they don't
want you to have consent over your
children they definitely want to press
their National Christian religion on you
they're white Christian nationalism on
you and your children
you can go to hell
they want to take away your [__]
libraries your education they don't want
publicly funded universities oh my all
these all these [__] Republican
Elites who went to publicly funded
universities don't want that [__]
anymore
they know that educates people they know
they know they'll know the truth
so what the [__] are you gonna do about
it huh
I'm talking to the audience what are you
going to do about it
it's time to get [__] loud
it's time to stay loud and pound the
drum day after day after day after day
I'll stand with brother Jones and Justin
Pearson and Gloria Johnson in Tennessee
to not give up
to not give up the fight not back down
to continue to push and lean into
democracy it is the vehicle that will
perform afford US rights and freedoms
that will deliver us the liberty equity
and equality for all in this country I
don't give a [__] what your skin color
what your religion what your gender I
don't give a damn democracy is the
vehicle
and it's it's a long hard Road it's not
easy democracy is tough
that's why that's why liberal
democracies are the strength and
principle of freedom
because it's a long hard fight
imagine imagine winning something that
isn't worth fighting for or having to
fight at all
that's what they do day in and day out
thoughts and prayers well thoughts and
prayers
you think thoughts and prayers are
difficult get the [__] out of here with
that [__]
with your empty ass thoughts
and your weak ass prayers
we got a goddamn country to say we got a
goddamn democracy to save we got Liberty
to protect
and It Ain't Easy
and it's not it's it's gonna continue to
get harder and harder
they're more radical they're more
extreme we see it in these state
legislators it's becoming more glaring
obvious
that our House of Representatives
is full of a bunch of criminal
extremists like Jim Jordan Jim Comer
trying to obstruct in the Manhattan DA's
investigation into Donald Trump probably
criminally obstruct
but as we look at our state houses and
see our state houses in each state
especially these red States
we now know that their blueprint to take
away our Liberty and turn us into a
fascist state
is being implemented and practiced tried
and these state legislators
you think Kevin McCarthy got up this
morning heard the news in Louisville and
went oh man we really need to do
something about this
I bet Kevin McCarthy is already received
half a dozen phone calls from either gun
lobbyist the NRA or gun manufacturers
themselves
this morning
and they're probably patting each other
on the back oh boy we're going to sell a
lot of guns today
Kentucky's gun sales just soared baby
yeah
there's 11 people got shot five of them
did we're gonna sell us a shitload of
ammo and a shitload of rifles in
Kentucky we're excited
that's how they feel this morning
Americans waking up going Jesus [__]
Christ are you kidding me
it's not it's not even 10 o'clock yet
and this is the [__] we got to deal with
in this country
and they're patting each other on the
backs can't wait for that profit to roll
in
they can't wait oh that's what they love
about mass shootings more than anything
that profit on the back end baby oh yeah
gun sales are going to soar in Kentucky
you [__] doubt me
you don't think that's their motivation
you don't you think you think all this
all these dead children all these dead
innocent people
the even the people who turn the guns on
themselves because the state let them
have it
aren't victims of profit the [__] out of
here with that [__]
you you believe Republican lies
I mean I get the delusional two-way Bros
out there like oh any kind of
infringement on my right is treason
that's not what it says but okay
bucko
people are [__] dumb as dog [__]
to think that we as a country don't get
too [__] regulate the militia
said it says right right [__] there
and by the way
to ABRA and I've been saying this I've
been telling you this
I'm talking to you two a Bros out there
you gun owners that love your guns want
to keep your guns want to keep buy guns
oh yeah
I'm talking to you here
when I'm telling you
if you like your [__] you better get to
the table and you better start
negotiating sensible gun reform fast I
mean really [__] fast
you're having more and more and more
people
being directly affected by long guns in
this country weapons of war tearing down
their family and their friends and
terrifying their communities and I'm
telling you when it hits home when it
hits enough homes especially
you're not gonna have your [__] guns
you're not you're gonna be left out in
the cold in these negotiations
we can't take you seriously
so you better get to the table
so you better stop listening to [__]
dribble and delusion
and [__] [__] lobbyist
you better stop doing it you better get
there fast
this generation's coming up
because we're Paving the way for
democracy here I don't know if you
noticed this
listen fascism is at our front door
but fascism is weak folks and I don't
know if you notice the people who are
backing fascism but they're dumb as a
[__] dumb as a goddamn Rock
they're not their best
for show
it may take a little bit but we will get
fascism to hide back underneath this
rock
Paving the way for democracy
and Liberty is only going to cause the
next Generation to make big decisions
for the country as a whole
instead of this [__] selfish ass
American Dream [__]
we've been deluded
by our own [__] that you can do with
me and have anything you want as long as
you're white you're a man
and if you're a woman you just sit down
or shut up you don't go to health care
and if you're if you're a person of
color well you just need to sit over
there in the corner and you need to just
deal with it
deal especially in Tennessee just deal
with it oh yeah if you're a transgender
person forget that you can't be that you
can't be that you can't wear a dress
definitely
if you want to
oh and you have to be a Christian
especially a white Christian nationalist
you think America's buying that [__]
look what happened in Kansas in the
special election for women's final
economy look what happened in the 2022
midterms in Michigan Michigan is going
to be the only state where this drug if
this if this goes into effect might be
legal
because they put it in the law they said
it on a referendum look what happened in
Wisconsin
folks the first liberal Court in 25
years
Arizona Pennsylvania
Wisconsin Michigan on the state level in
2022 for Governor's Secretary of State
and attorney general
the people said no to crazy ass Q Anon
trumped up fascist
no go [__] yourself
the wind of Liberty is at our back folks
we just have to open the sails of
democracy
it will Deliver Us rights Freedom equity
and equality
again it won't be easy
it will not be an easy fight
they are hell-bent on tearing us apart
just look at what the ex-president the
Cheeto dust q and honor was calling for
over the weekend World War III that was
his Easter message are you [__]
[__] me
how Christian of him
oh [__]
but now's the time to get loud
Now's the Time to dig the heels of
democracy in
I know I told you that 2022
the midterm was the most important
election in our democracy's history to
that point and it was
well
we won a lot of those fights
because we were loud
because we were proud
because we did not give a [__]
and Now's the Time to do the same for
2024.
you want to win back the United States
House of Representatives you want to
push forward on the Senate do you want
to win some more State houses we won
State houses
do you want to win some more Governor's
races
I know we're going to win the presidency
that's gonna be an easy one
but it's up to you I only have one
microphone
you had thousands
thousands of microphones
it's time to use them not just on social
media
you gotta talk to your family and your
friends
you think you think your family and
friends who support Trump Saw His World
War III message hell no I ain't paying
attention to that [__]
there's about one percent of his cult
that watches his [__] post every day
over on fraud social
and there's another [__] five percent
of the country that watch it to be
appalled by it can't believe that they
still support this [__] idiot
but they do and they will
but the thing they support more than
anything and they don't even know it
they don't know it they have no clue
yes I'm calling
a bunch of Americans brain dead idiots
they're delusional
they have no idea what fascism is
and they have no idea that they're the
baddies they just don't know
well it's time to turn up the volume and
let them [__] know everyone stick
around we'll be right back
right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
oh boy
couldn't say it better than Monday in
America yeah
and how how in the hell how in the hell
are are we even in the situation
where there's this much garbage wrapped
up in one holiday weekend it's almost
like they waited for this stuff
you know what I mean
[Laughter]
the war of three Grandpa let me let me
show you this is [__] real I'm not
making this [__] up let me show you this
here
this is Easter
right
yesterday was Easter Sunday
and that you know you'd expect the
president or next president or you know
a former president to put out a message
of love and
Christianity and holding hands and
family and food and holidays and
patriotism
this was Donald Trump's message
yesterday yeah I know he had another
rant
but that was the same old [__] the
same old whining
he whines like a little [__]
every day he whines like a little [__]
so it's not surprising that he whined on
Easter for like a little [__]
but here is here's his one message you
have to say World War III he's calling
for it that's what he's doing
he's not saying there is World War III I
mean he keeps saying oh the Democrats
you get a argument bringing in the World
War III
what he means is is I want my I want my
cult to go to world war three with
Democrats that's what he means
[__] him that's what he means now this
is an hour this screenshot of the
of the fraud social post was an hour
after it was posted right
if you look at if you look at the
numbers here this is why I'm saying I'm
telling you your family who support
Trump or your [__] people who run
around town supporting Trump have no
[__] idea the [__] he's posting look
at the numbers here
under 7 000 people like this thing in
less than an hour
[__] only has like five million
followers on his own social media
um website
only five million
half of those half of those followers
are people who are following it just to
keep track of the crazy [__] he's saying
probably
another half for [__] fake
but this this is what he's calling for
this is what he wants is world war three
now what Civil War but now it's World
War III and the reason why is because
he's on the side of Putin
oh don't believe me you don't believe me
oh you didn't hear the other news this
[__] weekend
seems to be all sorts of top secret
documents being linked online
looks like someone took a picture of him
I don't know maybe on a desk at a golf
course I don't know how am I supposed to
[__] know
how am I supposed to [__] know where
the pictures were taken of these
documents
hmm
makes you think
makes you think doesn't it
hmm
did you know Donald Trump was the
biggest leak out of his White House
that's right he was the leaker almost
every single time he was the leaker and
the reason why is because Donald Trump
wants to stay in the news he thinks
that's good for him
[Laughter]
yeah that's funny [__]
that's funny [__]
who do you think's linking these
documents I told you
a while back that we found out that some
of these documents
copies of them may have ended up on a
thumb drive
well what was in Jared kushner's pocket
when he went to the world cup with Elon
Musk and the Saudis was there a thumb
drive in his pocket I don't know I just
I just can't
I can't see it right I can't see what's
in his pocket I'm just saying that it's
a possibility probably and we're
wondering we're wondering how these
[__] documents got online
are you serious
we're Wonder we're wondering this
[Music]
I find it funny but this is this is the
official Easter message of the former of
the former
Cheeto dust cue in honor president World
War III
how how cute
how cute
but it says more about their party in
him than it does about us
doesn't it
I mean because some people were appalled
oh man he's calling for violence no one
moved
did you notice that
he called for world war three on his
social media platform this weekend
there wasn't a March not a protest
there wasn't violence they didn't cause
an uprising
not a goddamn thing
last week when that [__] was
arraigned
on 34 felonies
in New York
did you see this bit oh my god did you
see all the Trump sporters they went up
there and they they weren't doing
anything in his favor nothing [__]
nothing crickets [__] crickets
do you know why
it's a [__] fraud
this idea that he has massive support is
only built on one thing and I've been
telling you what it is over and over and
over and over and over and over again
there's only one thing holding the
entire fraud together
it's affiliation that's it
that's all it is I'm telling you I've
seen it with my own two eyes growing up
in White America
I'm telling you it's affiliation
you know what I'm talking about
you're all standing around there's about
12 white dudes at a party all drinking
queer beer Bud Light because they're
gonna keep drinking Bud Light
is there a bunch of dumb [__] Coors is
gayer than Bud Light if you want to go
into it we'll get into the details if
you want me to
but they're all standing around drinking
Bud Light with rainbows on the cans
and there's one guy out of the twelve
who's completely [__] delusional like
some of these trolls that are in this
chat completely [__] delusional have
no clue what the hell they're talking
about
about what Americans want what America
is they live in their own little white
America bubble they have no clue of the
world that lives outside of their little
privilege nothing not a goddamn clue
and they love Trump they still get Trump
Flags older elections stolen Biden's not
actually the president
Trump's running the country for morologo
every Q Anon [__] thing you can think
of that one dude
that one dude who has switched from Bud
Light to Coors Light and he doesn't even
know that Coors Light's gayer than Bud
Light I'll give you a proof later if you
want that Coors is gayer than Bud Light
just saying I'm not saying it's a bad
thing I'm it is Coors Light is is
more has been for gay rights longer than
Anheuser-Busch you dummies anyways
a switch to Coors he's got his Coors hat
on his cougars jacket
he bought him some Coors pajama pants to
wear to the party to prove that he
wasn't queer
but he loves Trump in that group he
loves him some [__] Trump he would
[__] Trump if you let him I mean he's
not gay you know
but he would [__] Trump if he had the
chance definitely suck him off
but Earl your cousin Earl that's
standing in that group of 12 white dudes
won't shut up about Trump won't shut up
about how much he [__] loves him and
everyone everyone in that group's
thinking in their minds this guy is a
dumb [__]
but I'm not gonna rock the boat
because I don't know how many of these
other these [__] white guys here
think the same thing I do that he's full
of [__] [__]
that's affiliation
go along the get along
cowardice
these people are cowards
they don't know about our Civics they
don't even know we're a constitutional
Democratic Republic they don't even know
that a representative Republic is a
[__] form of democracy they stand
around and tell each other's [__] at
their KKK meetings
we're not we're not a mock we're sleep
we're a republic
we're we're a constitutional
representative Republic go look it up
you [__] idiot
it's it's a form of democracy
but that's the only reason why this
exists is affiliation
White
privilege
male
snowflake them
it plays out in the beer conspiracy
I said over the weekend this is a result
of queer beer and woke M Ms this is it
this is the delusion
and they think this guy's gonna be
president
wait until everyone sees that this is
what this guy [__] sent out on Easter
I'm telling you
he's going to be their nominee
he's already levered more attacks
against Ron DeSantis
and I told you last week that Rhonda
Santos window opened but it's closing
fast again
and it will open and close open and
close open and close and if Rhonda
Santos doesn't strike which I hope he
does I hope Ron DeSantis gets in this
race there's nothing that would please
me more than to watch Donald Trump
absolutely burn Ron DeSantis political
career to the [__] ground and piss on
the ashes
after he napalms him
oh nothing would please me more [__]
that guy
Donald Trump is going to be indicted
probably three maybe four more times
in three or four more different
arraignments
by the time we get
to the 2024 election but he will be
their nominee
because of delusion because of
affiliation
I mean you have people in the chat right
now right now
saying the same delusional [__] that
they're going to say next year that's
going to propel him to the goddamn
nomination please moderators don't get
rid of them oh man
it's fantastic
to show show the pure delusion even in
the chat
these people come listen to me every
[__] day they can't stop listening to
me
from the very beginning from the time
that my music goes up until I cut the
broadcast they watch
they watch
keep watching
because I'm gonna show you your delusion
I'm going to show you why you're going
to lose
I will be correct
because if you've been watching long
enough you know how correct I am on a
regular [__] basis
I was correct about 2022.
there was no Red Wave I was saying it
for months ahead of time
I was correct when I said Donald Trump
will be indicted in the spring
huh
I was saying that at beginning of the
[__] year
so doubt me on this
doubt me he's gonna be the nominee this
guy calling for world war three on
Easter with 6 000 likes in an hour
I'm telling you your family your friends
the people around you they don't know
this exists
let them know this exists let them know
this was his Easter message
let them know
say it tweet it show it to him on your
phone
I'm telling you
we have to get loud
it's time
to crush fascism in this country
and a lot of people say oh well you have
Tony has trumped Arrangement syndrome
they have trumped Arrangement Center
Trump Arrangements send them Central
what the [__] are you talking about you
mean I'm against fascism yeah if that's
what you're saying yeah yep
yep that's what it is
I'm against fascist
and fascism
across the board
doesn't bode well with me
it doesn't compute with democracy or
Liberty
so I don't like it
and I'm gonna fight against it with my
microphone so are you going to use yours
it's the best weapon we have
it's the ultimate best weapon we have
so use it Gabe Sanchez is going to be
joining us here in just a few minutes I
believe we're going to go to the
shitless Roundup
and boy we got all kinds of [__] to
round up
all kinds of there's just news
everywhere
it I mean really honestly
it's going to take a long time to get
people up to speed
it really is it's gonna get people up to
speed on on all these [__] things
and I'm gonna try to keep you
um in the loop here with what's going on
but it's difficult with only two hours a
day with knowing the threats
that we have to our democracy and to our
Liberty and our freedom one of those
threats is apparently
Harlan Hitler buying up judges
that's right Clarence Thomas is a Harlan
Hitler funded judge
I call him Harlan Hitler because we we
learned last week
Lance Clarence Thomas was taking
millions of dollars in luxury gifts and
undisclosed payments in gifts trips
hotels Resorts Yachts flights these are
gifts this is payment
any any other one of us was receiving
this the government would [__] tax us
for this [__]
it's the way it would be
and if we were in a government
position we would have to disclose these
things
McLaren's Thomas felt that he didn't
need to tell us that he was being funded
by Harlan Hitler now who is Harlan
Hitler
who's Harlan Hitler Harlan Hitler is
Harlan Crowe a billionaire from Texas a
fascist I'm not just saying that again
out of nowhere
this this [__]
not only does he have a have a signed
portrait of Hitler hanging on his wall
proudly like out in the open
out in the open this isn't like he he
has a collection and he's got it
archived somewhere in a warehouse
for history historical purposes right
this thing is proudly displayed in his
house he loves this [__] thing matter
of fact he keeps it right near his
signed autographed copy of mineconf you
can't make this [__] up you can't you
can't make this [__] [__] up
can't make it up this guy has a signed
copy
Harlan Hitler who is funding DA's judges
politicians uh councilman all over the
country apparently
he's giving all kinds of lavish gifts to
all kinds of people who owe him favors
maybe I don't know they're looking into
it
but people have confirmed it yet not
only does the [__] have a signed
autographed copy of Minecon from Hitler
the guy loves it some [__]
he loves oh man he loves it what the are
you what the [__] what the [__]
look I'm not for Banning books I
actually think that I actually think
that people should should know a little
bit of that what is in that delusional
[__] book of Hitler's mind conf
maybe if they [__] knew what was in
that goddamn book they'd see the right
now what the hell is going on in this
[__] country
maybe they would
maybe they'd understand what the hell is
happening
to our [__] country if they read just
a little bit of that delusional piece of
work that Hitler put out
while he was in prison for trying to
commit a coup
wow
but this guy's got an autographed copy
and he loves that [__]
loves that [__]
and not only does he love the book he
loves he loves buying influence with
Clarence Thomas apparently
he loves it
Falcon loves it hails to the yeah
I mean why wouldn't Harlan Hitler want
to buy influence from a Supreme Court
Justice
huh why wouldn't he especially
especially influencing people like his
like Clarence Thomas's Q Anon wife Genie
hmm
why wouldn't he I mean we have tons tons
of Sorrows funded brat scooters right
right
so now we have Harlan Hitler
funded judges
say it
I'm telling you go out into the world
into the comments
and start saying Harlan Hitler funded
judges Harlan Hitler funded DA's Harlan
Hitler funding let me ask do you think
that it's possible that somehow someway
Cameron Sexton
the Speaker of the House in Tennessee
somehow some way I almost bet
I almost bit
in some form or fashion hence received
payment from Harlan Hitler
and I would imagine I would imagine that
that has influence on what he does hmm
I would imagine I would imagine listen
I'm trying to give you ammunition here
I'm trying to give you the weapon that
you need this is it
this is it folks
this is it
we're gonna have a lot we're gonna have
a lot
of battleground
in the next two years because it's not
just going to end with the 2024 election
I'm telling you
it's not just going to end there we're
gonna go all the way up to it and we're
gonna go past it because they're gonna
be like oh we didn't lose
we never lose we never lose Democrats
it's all cheated I mean it's only when
we win is when we win when we lose we
win too
and seeing you're going to be crying and
whining
like little [__] [__]
like they constantly are whining and
calling for world war three on Easter
I wonder how much money Donald Trump
received from Harlan Hitler
I don't know that's a good question
right that's a good question
should we see shouldn't we see
who who are receiving money from Harlan
hey they're apparently his brother
um likes to make money trafficking sex
trafficking apparently I don't know
that's what that's what they're [__]
saying people are saying there's people
out there saying that Harlan Hitler's
brother is a sex trafficker
I mean it's kind of on brand for
republicans and for fascists it really
is on brand we see them on time and time
again
doing these things
what what do you want from me
I just come here to tell you
so how many judges out there
is wait wait wait
is this judge in Texas is this judge in
Texas who just got rid of a pill for for
Women's Health Care is he is he uh a
Harlan Hitler funded judge
foreign
maybe we should be asking these
questions maybe we should be asking if
this judge in Texas
who has tried to strip away the bodily
autonomy from women the health care
choice of women to take a pill safer
than Tylenol I wonder if he's a harlem
Hitler funded judge
is he
it's a good question
we should be asking
we should be asking these questions
is it that is it that is it that out of
turn that we would be asking these
questions shouldn't we know if the judge
who made a sweeping decision in Texas is
funded by Harlan Hitler
Clarence Thomas is obviously funded by
Harlan Hitler
why else would Clarence Thomas take
luxury gifts
from a billionaire in Texas who loves
Adolf Hitler why else would he do that
is there any other reason why Clarence
Thomas would receive millions of dollars
in luxury gifts from Harlan Hitler
we must ask ourselves these questions
and just because we're asking ourselves
these questions doesn't mean anything
other than we just need the knowledge to
know exactly the answers that we seek
folks it's time to get real
on this Battleground
and if you want to get real on this
Battleground it is time to take the game
right to him
get their playbook and play the [__] out
of it
what do you think Gabe Sanchez you think
I'm on to something here I tried I tried
to float to you over the weekend yeah
yeah you're good landed on Harlan Hitler
funded judges that's the one I landed on
Harlan Hitler funded judges that's what
I learned yeah yeah yeah yeah I think
that works when you sent when you sent
it to me I was literally in my car
filming oh I was like oh really setting
up to film it what was that so it's like
I was like what I was like I can't do
this right now and then when I finished
I uh oh okay yeah but yeah but yeah well
it was Easter I figured you might be you
know eating drinking or starting world
war three I don't know apparently world
war three you know three days later
Christ rose from the dead did I miss
that part of it uh maybe I missed that
part I think that's the part that a lot
of people missed is is when you break
down the numbers of it you're like world
war three three three three three three
three three Pete Bulls Chicago Michael
Jordan Jesus God God goat
sheep yeah Ivermectin covid yeah China
Donald Trump oh my God that's the
magonomics I don't know that was off the
dome right now I just want to let you
know that I was able to make that uh
Association and if I can do that then
imagine what what Maga could do what
Maga can do
oh my God I mean it really is kind of
stupid right like how could anyone take
this seriously because the main point is
is that he typed this out on his machine
hoping something would happen and
nothing happened besides people laughing
there's a there's a part of me that's
wondering if Trump is like if he has you
know how people are like hey you know we
have to it's like Words of Affirmation
right we have to like bring it out there
and we need to make it a thing and we've
got our vision board and all this right
I wonder if Trump has a vision board and
it literally just says world war three
because every time you makes a video
he's always warning about how Biden and
in the left and all this stuff
he'll just be in front of the video and
he'll be like world war three
you know and it's it's one of those
things where you feel like
it's almost like he's projecting this
out there to be like I hope I hope I
hope world war three happens just so I
can say I told you so
and it's kind of [__] up to be like oh
this guy's this guy is hoping for World
War III right you don't talk about World
War III that much and try to use
fear-mongering if you're not actually on
the other end hoping that it happens to
say told you right and I think that's
true with Donald Trump when it comes to
uh Tweeting or you know truthing about
it or whatever it's it's a fact
especially on like a day for Easter
right I know that Trump isn't religious
but like on a day of Easter it's like
hey whoa whoa wait a second I thought he
was the most Christian president ever in
the history of ever ever in all time
ever he is the orange Jesus doesn't mean
he's necessarily super religious right
you know he's got a golden uh you know
he's a basically got a golden calf right
and CPAC 2021 they had a golden statue
was made after Trump right [__] false
deity that everyone
um that everyone puts out there but uh
it's it's just the fact that Trump when
he talks about World War III it's he has
that desire he wants it to happen he
wants world war three to take place so
that he can take credit
or or and or then say oh well the only
way for you to fix it is to put me in
place but the only reason that we're in
the situation we're in is because of
trump and we're trying to get out of
those types of uh you know domestic and
foreign
um conflicts right but
that's just that's holy [__] you got to
see this tweet so I'm trying to find
some [__] on the on the shooting this
morning in Louisville have you been
following uh no I did hear that five
I think they're including the shooter in
that five
um that are dead and there's six that
were wounded apparently there was a few
officers that were in the gun battle
that were
um very critically wounded but here is
um this is CNN had at the time uh five
people dead six taken to the hospital
after down um downtown Louisville
Kentucky mass shooting this is at a bank
apparently it's scrondled employee and
Witnesses on the ground were saying
there was a long rifle used MSNBC here's
their headline five people killed in
Louisville mass shooting six others
badly wounded Fox News decided to go
with this
chicken sandwich Wars so not world war
three but chicken sandwich Wars Popeyes
announces a new sandwich is that a real
graphic that's real like the top the
chicken sandwich Wars is the bottom part
of that Chiron doesn't look right it
doesn't well maybe it isn't real but I
mean go see if this is [__] real I
don't know if this is real come on um
would you believe it if it was I mean I
believe it but also I'm like as someone
who has [__] around with photoshopping
chirons and making people believe no not
you not you well here's here's something
that is real here's something that is
real here's the guy who represents uh
the district there in Louisville you
know what this guy is
oh yeah
Thomas Massey yeah Thomas Massey I
wonder if he's the one who got [__]
reamed by uh Jamal Bowman a week and a
half ago yeah over uh gun violence right
no I don't think he's a real man this is
not real it's not I think this is I
think this is a joke
like I get where they're coming from but
it's definitely not real
so I want to show you yeah because also
in here it says the previous host chili
cancel on short notice this is an old
graphic
here is here is um the scene downtown
you can hear the shots being fired
apparently law enforcement was there
just minutes after um the person arrived
on the scene also Tony at a bank
owned their
um aren't there people I don't know
let's say good guys with guns
well there were good guys on the scene
with guns in the building where the
shooting was right well and apparently
they were there all the time right from
nine to five right right armed guards I
think is where you're going with this
um listen every every person who has a
gun who's a bad guy with a gun starts as
a good guy with a gun they start out as
a good guy because see it's legal to buy
guns so you're a good guy you're a Law
buying Citizen and I'm sure this person
whoever this person is uh started off as
a good guy with a gun they were a good
guy they were a law-abiding citizens
trying to protect themselves just trying
to have that well-regulated militia and
they started out as a good guy with a
gun man good guy's [__] is all [__]
right it's [__] more guns means more
death that's just that's just the plain
simple fact of what we're going through
in this country if you don't like it you
can go [__] yourself you can take your
thoughts and prayers and you can stick
them straight up your ass all the way up
in there [__] all the way with with
your dumb stupid logic that more guns
means more safety you're a dumb [__]
right um and again you can hear the
shots
um in this video from this uh what seems
to be someone who's a bystander there on
the ground in Louisville in downtown
Louisville have you ever been to
downtown Louisville
uh I've never been to Louisville I've
been to Nashville right and uh yeah
never been never been to con uh oh wait
no no no never been maybe I'm trying to
think if I drove through it because I
went to
Gatlinburg Tennessee but I'm trying to
remember if I ever drove we drove out of
there
to it now I don't know if I've been to
Louisville myself it would have been
years ago but I don't think so it's been
a long time since I stopped in
Louisville when I was a kid we went to
the Slugger Museum and um you know so we
I watched I watched the bats being made
and we went to the the Slugger Museum
there in Louisville and I drove drove
through a couple times but I haven't
stopped maybe at a gas station took a
piss or something
um but you know how that goes so they're
more dead more dead it's just a Monday
morning in America folks right that's
what it is
you know the last two weeks right we I
mean today I think there's the vote
that's happening in Nashville in terms
of uh of repealing the expulsion of both
Justin Pearson and
um
uh uh Justin Jones Justin Jones and I
think that's happening today this
afternoon if I remember correctly yeah
it looks like Justin Jones Is Gonna soar
through the council wants him to be the
interim representative to represent
their District because that's who people
voted for right um they didn't vote for
Republicans those constituents didn't
vote for Republicans to take him out of
their seat because he got loud for
for five or ten seconds you know oh
they're Republicans feelings just got
her too hurt too hurt to hear them loud
noises it seems to be he gave Sanchez
that loud noises is the fascist
Kryptonite it really is yeah yeah I mean
[Music]
very delicate little [__] ears right
you know
what does that look like a little
[__] or something yeah oh man like it's
not like oh [__] ears like Puss in
Boots like it's always so cute you know
it's like little [__] ears like these
[__] little
you know [__] ears like oh nothing oh
nothing over like normal talking volume
in a room all got inside voices
that is what they do
it's they are so sensitive to sound
to uh facts to research to science to
logic
to empathy like these are things that
aren't radical right they're not [__]
radical caring for another person making
sure that we don't allow other people to
kill other people by limiting or
restricting the amount of firearms
assault weapons like it's just that it's
just
it's
every day I wake up and I'm like oh man
what are the Republicans gonna [__] and
moan about today instead of you want to
know you want to know I'll give you an
idea I'll give you an idea this is new
here's here's more news Okay Donald
Trump is appealing to uh ruling
rejecting his challenge to the grand
jury subpoena for former vice president
Mike Pence testify in the January 6th
Pro per person familiar Trump lost on
executive privilege and it really was
Pence that lost on Trump's executive
privilege Pence on the legislative
privilege he's trying to fight on behalf
of Pence now so Pence won't talk and
Bloomberg has it here when was the hold
on when was the last time that Donald
Trump defended Mike Pence he's been
[__] on Mike Pence for years now
Bloomberg has it here Trump appeals
ruling that Pence has to testify to
January 6th and that's how you know he's
[__] scared uh while he was you know
it's funny because he stopped really
messaging about uh Alvin Bragg because
he knew that that was not gonna go well
if I do more I'll be in trouble right
right he's well he doesn't want that gag
order right yeah yeah because when he's
got a gag order then he's really [__]
yeah um but but so he started to go
after Jack Smith but and it seems some
people were like oh well Jack Smith must
be getting close and I'm like must be
are you [__] have you not been paying
attention [__] he's gonna he's gonna
talk to Mark Meadows Scott Perry Mike
Pence are you kidding me this guy's
winning all over the place the only
thing that Jack Smith has lost so far is
this legislative argument that Mike
Pence made and Mike Pence won and is not
going to appeal that and I believe it's
because Mike Pence is going to take that
win right now rather rather the
Department of Justice and Jack Smith
appeals that decision for the
legislative privilege then maybe they
will but Mike Pence is like hell no
that's the one I said I wanted it's the
same one that Lindsey Graham tried to
use in Georgia right right and the idea
is that because I was the I presided
over the joint session I have
legislative privilege and I'm not part
of the executive branch in that act so
you can't you can't subpoena me
um from for my executive
um um my executive privilege but my
legislative privilege right Lindsey
Graham tried this and he lost he lost in
Georgia over this
um and Mike Pence won this decision so
that's why he's not going to appeal
because he'll probably he would probably
so Donald Trump's going to appeal this
matter now I'm not sure exactly the
difference here in the appeal but it
says Donald Trump is appealing the
executive privilege measure that that
Mike Pence lost here as he'll have to
um actually be subpoenaed and appear
before the January 6 grand jury now this
is a criminal grand jury and that's one
reason why Mike Pence doesn't want to go
in front I mean I I don't know anyone
that would really have any kind of
criminal liability would want to go in
front I have a [__] grand jury
especially a special counsel again
nothing to hide
you've got nothing to hide then then you
know if if whenever you hear someone say
I'm innocent I'm innocent but I'm not
going to go and testify right I'm not
going to give my deposition I'm not
going to go give a statement it's like
well if you have nothing to hide and you
truly are innocent then why wouldn't you
just comply why wouldn't you just
Kyle Chaney has it it's docket number
23-3049 it's a sealed case
um but it it is showing uh case type
information grand jury other Criminal
is that where we're calling Trump now
other criminal he's the other criminal
he's the other one right
um but this is this is Trump has
appealed The Secret order requiring
Pence testified to January 6th grand
jury uh reflected here in the sealed
docket entry again Kyle Chaney has it
here that um and this is um this is all
within the last 20 minutes
um this has happened here so
oh boy it seems like seems like uh the
war prosecutor
is moving closer what do you know about
these Elite documents I keep getting a
message
um from Mario's team I was busy other
week the Pentagon ones yeah Mario's team
keeps wanting me to go speak in these
spaces about these um leaked documents I
honestly have not even looked into it I
just know from what I understand there
were documents that were that were
leaked from the Pentagon that uh gave
info or
allowed people to get an idea of you
know what's going on in terms of U.S
intelligence on our allies and our our
enemies and and some of it is the
collection of Russian um intelligence
right right
um yeah and so it's happened in the last
few weeks I mean again like I haven't
really looked into this there is an
investigation I do know that from the
doj that's looking into the leaks as to
how they happened right because the U.S
military documents that are classified
so you know in the same way that we're
like oh [__] why did Trump have these
classified documents you know we're
wondering also okay how did these wait
you're wondering why I had the
classified documents no no no I'm saying
like in the same reason the doj Smith is
looking to do it we know why I know why
everyone knows why but what I'm saying
is like in the same way that they're
treating to be like oh we need to look
into these documents that he took right
there the doj is launching another
investigation into uh classified
documents in relation to this right so
right because it's sensitive sources
that compromise also important for
relationships uh anyone who might be
required to have their identity uh
suppressed or hidden that's overseas I
mean spies whatever it might be like
there are
I think if I um
if I remember correctly it had they also
revealed stuff about the Ukraine
Weaponry air defense uh uh the Readiness
the critical point in the war uh stuff
about Ukraine in addition to into the
addition to the military
um
but I don't I haven't I this is all like
me reading like headlines and getting
like a quick synopsis but I don't know
like yeah Mario
wants me to go into this Twitter space
yeah they invited me this weekend and I
was like I I was like I'm how's he
filming I was like I'm doing what was
that I'm I don't have time to read this
stuff right now I had family [__] and I
wanted to lay around and be lazy to be
quite honest I mean you know what
sometimes you just gotta do that you
just want to be [__] lazy
um here is let's go to the Harlan um
Hitler I mean Harlan Crow story yeah I'm
gonna call him Harlan Hitler I don't
give a [__] I I hope that [__]
I'll I'm I'm gonna defame him if I can
maybe he'll sue me and then we'll make
some [__] Discovery [__] that yeah
I'm here here is a patriot takes look
look who showed up this is Speaker Kevin
if you don't recognize these [__]
schlubs this is Speaker Kevin McCarthy
Senator Tim Scott and Chris Christie at
the heartland Crow Library I wonder if
this is in the mineconf room is this in
the Minecon it's in the library so you
no no it literally is all of these
events that he has when uh when Clarence
Thomas swore in there's another judge I
was I was looking because I was I'm
gonna be doing a what was that on this
because it's the whole [__] thing is
crazy right like it's there have been
signs of this
political meddling and influence for
years
but it's like an article comes out in
2004. an article comes out in 2010 2011.
an article comes out in 2016 or whatever
another really no one ever really does
anything right they're like ah well you
know and then then this propublica story
comes out and like look
lots of money has been spent on this guy
and no one's done [__] and for anyone to
argue oh there's nothing Shady here at
all
is either dumb or they're in on the
Hitler coup right right
well it makes me it makes it it makes me
feel like all the George Soro stock
because that's what they're doing well
yeah
always always look how uncomfortable in
this photo these three men look
standing in the mind conf room of I mean
Harlan Hitler Library yeah I don't know
I mean they're also passing out drinks
this guy has maybe champagne or
something that's a yell maybe it's piss
I don't know if you look down in the cup
on the guy that's here in the in the
frame it looks pretty yellow
um unless you know unless it's like
[__] Mellow Yellow drink it looks
like it could be piss now maybe maybe
that's what Harlan Crow does when he has
his little Hitler parties is he's like
hey everyone you got to drink the
Kool-Aid
the Kool-Aid's my piss or he's like the
Kool-Aid is Hitler's piss that I've had
on [__] uh and Refrigeration this
whole time oh but in this you're saying
this could be this could be uh I'm
saying I'm saying Harlan Crowe loves to
drink piss
you heard it here first Harlan Crow
loves to drink piss and serve that his
name was Harlan Hitler no I mean that's
you know on like if we're talking public
name oh you know it's Harlan crows
whatever your name is the name that he
uses between his friends right like
Kevin McCarthy uh uh Tim Scott uh Chris
Christie Clarence Thomas Jenny Thomas
Ted Cruz any of these guys
it's Harlan Hitler for sure uh because
that's what he is right nobody simps I
don't know it's I would there's a part
of me that wonders
if there's anyone that simps harder for
Hitler than Harlan Crowe
I don't know I don't know you've got
memorabilia on [__] dictators you've
got memorabilia for for Nazi memorabilia
like that stuff where you're like why
are you collecting this stuff well like
you know why in a museum for people to
learn from not for you to [__] jerk
off to I got I've got a uh a response
from the owner of the fascist rag daily
wire apparently he's he's speaking on
why you would own these artifacts
because I'm not I'm not I'm not saying
these artifacts aren't part of history
and they shouldn't be yeah cataloged
it's history again for the public right
I definitely don't think that you should
be displaying them proudly in your
[__] you're like look here look at
this right I love this [__] Hitler
portrait oh my God and he signed it too
and look here I got a sign Gap in your
mind God do you ever signed copy of mine
Camp I do I [__] do I mean it's kind
of weird I'm just gonna say but let's
see let's see how weird Ben Shapiro
thinks it is let's see if um he thinks
um if he can get his wife's [__] wet
with a signed copy of mine comp maybe
maybe that's where bench beer goes I
mean maybe that's what he needs you just
need to soak me he needs to soak it up
because it's so wet right maybe that's
what it is let's let's listen and
apparently he's a very very bad man
apparently not allowed to be friends
with Justice Thomas because apparently
they're now accusing him I'm not kidding
you of being like a Nazi oh my god well
that I'm accusing you of being like a
Nazi Ben Shapiro you [__] Nazi you
and your Nazi [__] rag going around
trying to push legislation in States for
through your media organization with the
likes of Michael Knowles Candace Owens
and Matt Walsh to try to legislate
groups of people out of existence that
sounds pretty [__] Nazi to me [__]
okay let's keep let's keep going the
reason is because this is what Nazis do
they make friends with Clarence Thomas
that Nazis famous for loving black
people that this is one of the things
they're most famous for so Kevin Cruz
who is just a ridiculous human being a
pseudo academic over Princeton
University who has somehow avoided
plagiarism charges that have gotten
kicked out of the University he tweeted
out I've spent Decades of my life
researching and writing about white
supremacists and no I don't have any
paintings or statues of them in my house
because that's not something you do with
the people you hate what's he talking
out there well apparently Harlan Crowe
collects basically memorabilia from
defunct communist and Nazi States and he
has a garden in which he displays these
things to show what the what the
capitalistic free market and
judeo-christian ethic has overcome
oh my God
he's got a garden he paid he paid a lot
of money to make sure people know that
he doesn't like these people by
displaying them in his special Garden
where this is well what the [__] are you
talking about man this is this is great
this is great for them to have to defend
this this is fantastic to watch them do
this and the reason why is because
Harlan Hitler is running around America
funding DA's funding judges funding
politicians these are all Harlan Hitler
funded people hell I don't know maybe
the reason why Ben Shapiro maybe he just
and maybe Journal it if you're out there
in your journalism maybe you should look
into this maybe the daily wire is funded
by Harlan Hitler I don't know they they
claim we're [__] funded by George
Soros they claim we're funded by George
or so why wouldn't I have to assume that
a fascist read like The Daily wire is
funded like someone like Harlan Hitler
why why it's it's insane but I just
wanna there's something that he said at
the beginning in the clip where he's
like oh apparently you can't be friends
with these people if you're a Nazi right
or something to that effect which is
dude okay no one said you had to be
friends with these people okay and what
I mean by that is just because
Harlan Crowe is
taking him on these trips these last
vacations on the jet to his Million
Dollar Resort all this stuff
doesn't mean that he actually likes him
it means that he can tolerate him right
because it means that hey look if I get
this guy on the books
to influence him and these laws that I
might have someone
in this election or I might have someone
pushing this law you know locally
whatever
he doesn't have to like him he just has
to tolerate him enough so that he can
use his power and influence to say hey
Clarence I have this point of view on
something and I want you to return the
favor for all those freebies I gave you
right again he doesn't have to like him
he doesn't have to really be friends
with him if I at the end of the day if I
really looked at it maybe Harlan Crowe
thinks that he's friends or maybe it's
his uh he believes in some degree he's
like oh yeah well we do this so he likes
me so we're friends or whatever and he
also might be like well he's not one of
the bad ones right he's one of the good
ones and and it's like Jesus Christ I
can only imagine what Harlan Crowe
actually thinks of Clarence Thomas but
again he doesn't have to actually be
friends and like him he just has to
tolerate him enough so that he can
influence him to think oh you know what
the ends justify the means right and
that's what he wants
I was one of the first ones loudly
calling them Nazis every day on the air
yeah I continue to call him Nazis and
Stevie and Wonderland points it out here
Tony called it a while ago these people
are in point of fact now I mean if
you're hanging around a dude who's
idolizing Nazi memorabilia has a signed
copy of mineconf has a [__] penis
proud of it
he doesn't hide in like a vault in an
archive this [__] has it out on
display listen I I wonder if Ben Shapiro
I wonder if Ben Shapiro
believes that Harlan Hitler hasn't read
mind gov yeah and doesn't understand
what mineconf lays out and understand
that Justice Thomas is just a pawn in
the game to get what the fascists want
I mean when the fascists take over our
country and they turn our our state into
a fascist state do you believe that
Clarence Thomas is going to last long
and his wife Jeannie Thomas is going to
last much longer after that what are you
[__] kidding me Harlan Hitler will if
if he takes power if Harlan Hitler takes
Power by giving his money to Donald
Trump or any other fascists out there
you think you think Clarence Thomas is
going to survive long under a fascist
state
when Harlan Hitler has funded these
politicians these judges these DA's
these police officers who knows how deep
this conspiracy goes who knows he might
be buying dog catchers for all I know I
don't [__] I don't know
I it seems like he's funding the daily
wire I mean Ben Shapiro really seems to
be simping for Harlan Hitler here let's
listen apparently this now means you're
a fan of these things so if you own a
piece of memorabilia from an evil regime
in order to demonstrate to your children
so that people remember for the future
what that evil regime was this means
you're now a fan of that thing according
to Kevin Cruz okay these this is the
same [__] group of people who over
the last two weeks got so triggered
literally that they were they were
shooting at beer cans with rainbows on
them they're still doing it what the
[__] I mean seriously they're still
dumping it out they're still doing it I
find it funny over the weekend they
finally came around and realized that
Coors Light is gayer than Bud Light like
they didn't know that before the weekend
and now they're like wow are you sure
they know that because Kid Rock went to
the UFC fight with Donald Trump rocking
Coors jacket I I think it was Jack
prostate or Charlie Kirk said you have
to do an hour's worth of research to
figure out which beer to drink or some
stupid [__] and the reason why people
that this is so difficult for them to
understand they're they're not what they
say they are they've always been like
we're free market capitalists we're
conservatives they're not they're
[__] fascist they're [__] Nazis
you dumb sons of [__] listen if your
free market capitalist that's truly what
you are and you're a conservative for
the free market then you don't give a
[__] what companies use as a marketing
scheme to sell their product for profit
you dumb sons of [__] why don't you
believe that gay people drink beer
frankly there's probably there's
probably more cause for people who are
allies or in the lgbtq community to
drink beers they like the [__] party
they like to have fun what makes you
think they wouldn't like to partake in
alcoholic beverages like Bud Light Mill
like Coors Light or the like you stupid
bastards listen this is the dumbest [__]
I've ever heard of in my life but this
is the world that Ben Shapiro live in
where they can believe that we can't
have [__] rainbows on our beer cans
because that sends a symbolism that'll
make people gay but people who own
signed copies of mein Gump aren't Nazis
what the [__] why
tell me how this logic makes sense tell
me I want to know it makes perfect sense
okay let's hear it it makes perfect
sense rainbows on beer cans makes you
gay signed copies of mine comp that you
display proudly that you love and that
you are proud of and that you paid
gazillions of dollars or doesn't make
you a Nazi how does this logic line up
Gabe Sanchez tell me it's there it's
just the [__] woke left trying to
play tricks on us that's what I'm
telling you focus of course you know I'm
sure someone's gonna try to argue that
rain they're like oh well Rainbows are
gay because God made them and then
you're trying and it's like oh man
you're trying to confuse us you know us
religious people and then you're like oh
mind comp it was just one dude who got
really upset because he was rejected
from art school and took it out on
people's like maybe maybe you should
have been more loving so then there you
know it's this whole reverse psychology
they're gonna blame it on the woke left
and how it's our fault and how it's the
Democrats or the the the the
anti-fascist
or actually the cause of this they're
gonna say oh well you guys push this
person into that you guys rejected yeah
and Tifa did it well of course antifa is
against a [__] Supreme Court Justice
receiving undisclosed gifts and millions
of dollars of luxury yeah
from a guy who loves Hitler have you
ever seen have you seen Django Unchained
of course I have okay all right uh
Clarence town I could not see a greater
parallel you could not see I could not
see I could not see a greater parallel
yeah to Django Unchained
then Leonardo DiCaprio's character and
his Butler Stephen right the guy that
that character played by Samuel L
Jackson right exactly that is Clarence
Thomas right and Harlan Crowe is
Leonardo DiCaprio's character
that it's the [__] if there was a
someone go meme that [__] who would have
I well uh in a in a moment but God damn
it dude it is for sure that relationship
is in that film that's what it is
everyone's like oh Clarence Thomas is uh
you know whatever
no honestly that's [__] Clarence
Thomas he's Stephen he's Stephen the
butler the [__] guy who will will
simp for the racist bigoted white man
because he was able to sleep inside or
he was able to take a shower he was able
to get these benefits these gifts right
the same way Clarence Thomas is Clarence
Thomas makes like [__] 200 something
thousand dollars a year to be a Supreme
Court Justice okay how much does his
wife make undisclosed by the way we know
who knows I mean there was a here look I
know that's the new report when he when
he uh when he gave five hundred thousand
dollars to Jenny Thomas for her a little
tea party organization
she paid herself 120 000
um
uh at least at least 120 000 as a salary
while she was there who knows what she
makes now okay who knows what favor
she's doing and what you know what
private business is hidden between a
shell core and a shell core and a shell
core and a shell core for someone to not
disclose this stuff right Harlan Crow's
like I don't have disclosed [__] I don't
got to tell you where these donations go
and it's like oh thank you citizens
united where we have this influence by
billionaires and corporations where they
can stick their hands straight into the
[__] arm like into the into the
political pie that is the United States
and say you know what I want to add this
ingredient or I want to take out this
ingredient or whatever it is right and
and uh Clarence Thomas
is a is a simp and he is a servant for
people like uh you know Harlan Hitler
okay it's people like that who are
dependent
on that relationship right maybe
Clarence Thomas really does believe in
his mind he's like you know what this he
is my friend there's no such thing as
racism because this is a white guy who's
rich and he likes me for who I am and he
loves Hitler and he loves Hitler so
Hitler must have loved Hitler must have
loved Clarence Thomas how how can he be
racist right if he likes me he brings me
to all these things I don't know man
let's look at the [__] painting of
you guys on the deck all of these
influential people in their different
Industries
saying oh you know what
we don't need to hang out with Clarence
no you [__] do need to hang out with
Clarence Thomas the guy who's one of the
more powerful voices on the Supreme
Court to use him and knowing they're
like look you know uh Scalia he's gonna
die at some point this person they're
gonna die at some point like we need to
back our horse right we need to back our
mule here
and and bring our bring our own
initiatives and our own influence and
our own politics into the courtroom
whether directly or indirectly through
our influence right well you think you
think it was hard for Harlan Hitler to
realize that the Thomases were an easy
target when Jeannie Thomas in the 80s
was uh was a victim of cult announcers
Harlan Hitler knew exactly what he's
doing do you think Harlan Hitler when he
finds out that people are calling him
harder than Hitler if they if he draws
it back to this show on April 10th I
hope I hope somebody does a a link back
to be like where did Harlan where the
[__] did that start where did that come
from yeah and then they're like oh [__]
it was on the Tony Michaels show yeah
what's going on oh that guy's been
calling people Nazis for a long time huh
I wonder why let's let's listen to what
Ben how he simps how I can't even
believe I'm saying this this Coastal
Elite Jewish person Ben Shapiro who owns
a Nazi rag the daily wire who pushed is
fascism every single day on their
broadcast and on their print and in
their media I can't believe he's simping
for a [__] Nazi it's uh unbelievable
to me I mean are you though because you
have to remember that Ben Shapiro also
defended uh uh or okay here I'll
rephrase it he didn't defend Trump but
he didn't condemn him right right what
he said was oh maybe you know it didn't
even name didn't even name Trump after
he had dinner with Nick Fuentes and
Kanye West
right a known Nazi he didn't even say
that he said oh maybe if you don't want
people to talk about it then don't have
dinner or maybe if you don't want people
talking about the fact that you had
dinner with a Nazi or an anti-semite
then don't have dinner with a Nazi
anti-semite right okay but let's go a
little further Ben let's say the name of
the person that you're talking about but
this is you playing it safe so that when
Trump becomes the Republican party's
nominee you can be on the record of
saying uh I never criticized Trump
directly I never said I was just
commenting about this in general right
yeah in general let's see what in
general he talks about Harlan Heartland
Hitler
this this is the actual thing they're
going for yeah according to the
Washingtonian when Republican Mega donor
Harlan girl isn't lavishing Justice
Thomas free trips on his private plane
and Yacht he lives a quiet life in
Dallas among his historical collections
these collections include Hitler
artifacts two of his paintings of
European cityscapes a signed copy of
mineconf assorted Nazi memorabilia plus
a garden full of statues of the 20th
Century's worst despots
yeah it's all true that's all true again
dude the take the argument Ben's like
look uh apparently he's got that he's
got a library he's got a book a first a
signed copy of mine
he's got a garden a [__] garden with
statues of these terrible Garden yeah a
garden it's not it's not a [__]
Museum that's on somewhere that's
obscure that he has preserved these
items for historical value he has them
outside in a garden right [__] boat
he was like oh he's got these things
like okay this is you know what this
reminds me of it reminds me of uh Sean
Hannity playing the [__] clip of all
the crimes that Trump has committed and
he's like look at all these things the
people are attacking him for thank you
for looking in every rolling a scrolling
list of all this so when you when you
Ben Shapiro go through this list of
things that are true and don't look
great as someone who is Jewish Ben
Shapiro that you're defending a dude who
is a fan of Nazis and probably shares
those same [__] Nazi ideas is so sick
and demented and honestly I'm not
surprised considering what we saw with
Donald Trump and Nick Fuentes with Ben
Shapiro but the fact that he's like look
he's got all these terrible things
[__] Minecraft these these dictators
he's got these statues he loves
authoritarianism it's almost like Harlan
Hitler loves authoritarians you don't
collect something you're not a fan of
okay people don't collect [__] they hate
right you wouldn't be you wouldn't hate
Legos and be like oh look at all these
Legos I [__] collect and I build
together I [__] hate Legos Legos
Legos are terrible but I've got a lot of
money yeah you do not collect [__] that
you hate okay okay so so generally
speaking like if if there is a
philanthropist out there that wants to
preserve history right and then wants to
preserve artifacts whatever those
artifacts are generally they will work
um not just just in private but also
with other organizations who it is their
job and their Duty and their and and
their not just his life but beyond that
to preserve these artifacts right I mean
there's plenty of museums around the
world
that have horrific items in it that
they're I mean you you can go to a lot
of places and there's a lot of horrific
items from our history of slavery a lot
there's a lot of history there's a lot
of artifacts that's that show you what
we did during that dark time in America
and still leading up to today the civil
rights movement and Beyond there's a lot
of artifacts that are there but people
aren't like yeah man I'm gonna put it on
the wall I'm gonna put it on the wall
and I'm gonna have a signed copy of it
and I'm gonna show it to people I'm
gonna be proud no you work you work with
I don't know organizations that that
make sure people see this in museums
because I'm not saying I'm again I'm not
against Banning books I'm not against
um Banning Minecon honestly more people
in this country read a little bit of
mineconf and understood what Hitler was
trying to [__] say you'd be like whoa
[__] that's what they're saying now oh
my God no wonder why Tony's calling them
Nazis holy [__] you should read the [__]
they want to do in this book it's almost
like it's a it's a road map for what
Maga is trying to do in the United
States if more people would come to you
know to grips with that maybe we'd have
an easier time unwinding this [__]
like Ben Shapiro's trying to spew here
let's listen to the end of it
he said that he's filled his property
with these mementos because he hates
communism and fascism
well I mean that seems like
a reason why you might own this stuff is
to remember the things that you hate
that's it
but apparently this makes him a Nazi and
uh he he can't even he can't even keep a
straight face when he's like apparently
because if you have stuff that you hate
in your that makes you uh yeah
it's like Jesus Christ Ben Shapiro just
take
just take the L right and accept the
fact that you're a Jewish person
who is oh man I'm so red from doing that
uh you're right you know what they're
trying you know what they're trying to
do you know what he's trying to do here
he's trying to protect Clarence Thomas
because that yeah that really is because
they've been going on and on and on
about Soros prosecutors and Soros funded
this and sorrow Jesus Christ I've had it
in my comments for [__] years how I'm
funded by George Soros or the Democrat
Elite or whatever the [__] you know on
and on and on it goes which is all a
bunch of [__]
um that's they're all funded daily wire
uh Breitbart
um all of them are funded rushland ball
all these right wing talk radio there's
a lot of YouTube channels out there that
are funded by right-wing causes all of
them every [__] one of them the
reason why they say this [__] is because
that's what they're doing right and they
don't want you to know it so they're
accusing their enemy they're they're
people on their opposition of doing it
and it just doesn't happen folks
Democrats I'll tell you this
unfortunately Democrats don't give money
for media they don't they don't you know
what they do with their money you don't
want it when you give money to act blue
they buy they buy TV commercials that
that's what the [__] they do they buy
[__] TV commercials I hate to break
it to you that's what they say I mean
the only media that I think that that
people on the left donate to is like NPR
honestly when they do their little like
we're doing a fundraising Drive call in
give your money we'll give you a free
mug and a tote bag
well hello this is the NPR hi this is
and we are going to raise money for this
boring ass show today
I mean that's what it is but also like
if you're going to talk about money
that's going into these places like the
daily wire I mean we have to remember
that they offered 50 million dollars
50 million dollars to [__] uh Stephen
Crowder yeah and and Carter's like now
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna play to this
game where uh dude I don't like this
contract if my show doesn't do well you
don't pay me I mean that's kind of
standard contract but the fact that 50
million bucks dude I will do a lot for
50 million bucks okay
wait wait wait a second let's stop right
there let's stick I want to go through
this what would you do for fit what
would Gabe Sanchez I wish I had some
music
what would Gabe Sanchez do for 50
million dollars Gabe Sanchez give us
what you would do well the thing that I
have said before on the show was I would
take the 50 million dollars and I would
obviously you know I pay myself just to
exist in this world right but I would
take that money and also secretly fund
it into counter organizations
like I wish you well I mean against me
but also against just right-wing media
oh against right I would use that to
then fund right wing or a left-wing
media you know right because it's more
profitable is that what you're saying
well more profitable also I feel like
the money would go somewhere and also
it's like I've had this idea for a while
where I want to sell something that's on
Amazon that's super [__] right wing
but what people don't realize is that
inside of whatever that thing is like
there's a book where it's like oh here's
uh there's books with empty pages of
like Trump's accomplishments and stuff
like that right they sell those on
Amazon
I've always wanted to sell like flag
memorabilia or like [__] January 6
17. so you're just saying you want the
right you want to take advantage of the
right one yeah like if I'm gonna grift
money I'm gonna grift it from the right
under the guys that oh oh man this is so
patriotic but inside whatever that
product is hidden in the language hidden
in the the design hidden in whatever uh
it's going to be known that the thing
that they're showing the thing that
they're using the thing that they've
bought is actually a left wing product
and then the money that they pay me for
that product whatever it might be then
goes to fund left-wing organization
Planned Parenthood or something exactly
right you know that's that's funny
because we brought up we played the
trumpy bear commercial on this show and
I always thought that it was maybe that
thing but it's not it's real I want to
show you something else that's real
um this is uh Harlan Hitler's uh brother
his name is uh
tremel Trammell travel
Hitler here
um none of these guys made their own
money by the way no well do they do they
all got I mean trans white dudes do rich
white dudes ever come on man Trammel
Crow senior his name is Trammel you
wouldn't be like I know I've never I
didn't even know this was a name until I
saw this article this weekend when
they're like oh Trammel Crow Jr linked
to sex trafficking ring which is linked
to the woman that was formerly married
to Prince Andrew hmm seems kind of weird
yeah that the the Hitler's the Hitler
family the American Hitler family down
in Texas
um is linked to sex trafficking ring
seems Seems on brand doesn't it for
these Republicans I mean to me it does
at least I mean it's uh you know again
when there is a accusation it's always a
confession right right projection
projection so the idea that you've got
you know Mega donors on the Republican
side who want to say the the left is a
bunch of pedophiles and groomers and
creepos and perverts and you're like
okay let's just turn that back on you
guys because it turns out that most of
the time if not all of the time it's
your [__] priests it's your uh your
your local you know uh politicians you
know even in Tennessee even in Tennessee
you know you had
brother Jones calling out these people
he's like look you guys are calling for
my expulsion what about these guys and
went through a list there's a [__]
chair pisser for God's sakes I mean like
that was I was like what I was like what
what was that I was like [__] pissed
on a chair who does that these people
are so [__] twisted and sick that
they will do all these things and go oh
yeah there's nothing wrong with that
there's nothing wrong with that at all
just like Ben Shapiro being like oh this
guy's got all this Nazi memorabilia
there's nothing wrong with that at all
because it goes against it because what
it would do is him accepting the fact
or any Republican except in the fact
that people in their own party are
actually bad or working under like
malicious means would totally defeat
Their Own Foundation and their own
audience because then if he goes after
that then people like why should I trust
you you're attacking daddy Trump or
you're attacking the the right wing you
know you know policies which of which
I'm sure many people on the right will
say what's wrong with the little money
going into politics we do it all the
time
well what's wrong with money for a
dictators statues authoritarian statues
in a garden I mean literally this is a
garden
right right yeah this and these these
aren't things that are just like oh plop
I put it there like he's got a light so
he's like oh yeah I want to make sure
that nobody bumps into this at night I
want people to know about it well I mean
of course
and Patriot takes as uh some of the
pictures here from
from the garden of Heartland Hitler
again I'm not opposed to
preserving things for history and didn't
know I mean just like you know statues
right when you're taking down statues
you know during 2020 and 2021 it's like
you know those are things if you would
like to put into them wait wait wait
oh yeah this one Patriot takes as Harlan
crows you didn't see this collection
um this is Adolf Hitler's
you can't make this [__] up his teapot
engraved with the she wants to the gun
Hitler's initials yeah
I thought you saw this one I also want
to know where these photos came from
right like who took these I mean this is
someone with a cell phone you can see
the reflection there in the [__]
teapot no I get that but I want to know
who's who's getting all these photos
right are they just like out have they
existed out there on the Internet or or
did somebody go through did like a maid
or someone go through and be like Snap
Snap Snap Snap they're like finally
someone's [__] talking about this
terrible apparently he [__] he
[__] invites these people in and is
bragging about this [__]
I mean Let Me Whip out my signed copy of
mine comp already yeah right I mean I
had you people down here to tell you I'm
gonna pay you money right but um the
real thing I want to do is show you show
you my uh my thing right here I'll show
you my thing here's another one that
pays unsolicited mineconf pick right
right and whip it out well I mean how
else do you get out the signed copy of
mine comp besides just whip it out um
this is original painting by Adolf
Hitler right this is the people don't
know before Hitler was Hitler he was a
really shitty painter he was an aspiring
painter we'll give him we'll give him
that right he was an aspiring painter he
wasn't good you make your [__]
decision here where do you think this is
a good painting or not I mean here I'll
say signature down on the bottom makes
it a horrible I'll say this I'm not a
painter I couldn't paint this right but
I also don't think that he's a great
painter I think it I I look at this [__]
well hold on hold on what I'm gonna say
here is I'm not a painter I couldn't do
this
but when I look at this it reminds me of
everything else right like I've seen
this type of painting before or I've
seen [__] like this before where you're
like oh look it's a do you know why it
isn't iconic do you know why because
it's Hitler
Jesus [__] Christ listen this
painting should be archived somewhere in
a warehouse where it can be referred
back to of hey this is the [__] that
this guy used to do before he I don't
know committed genocide on six million
Jews okay before he became the dictator
of [__] the authoritarian of Nazi
Germany you know what I you know what I
think of right like obviously there's a
whole argument of like you know if it
was never uh you know not banned but
rejected from art school like would he
have become the person that he became
and it's quite possible yeah you know
um I mean honestly if you look I would
look at I would look at it like this
Hitler was the original
uh uh
Maga in cell shooter
he was rejected right because you know a
girl didn't like him or these people
didn't you know accept him or you know
he wasn't allowed into art school
because they didn't think it was good
enough or whatever it might be and then
instead of saying oh you know what
got it I'm either gonna try even harder
at this thing that someone said I can't
do or I'm going to try something else
right I'm going to get a new hobby I'm
just going to move on and say oh man
whatever and then the third one is he
goes nah [__] it I'm just gonna kill a
bunch of people because they didn't
accept me for who I am or you know who I
want to be right because again
in a world where Republicans make fun of
participation Awards
one of the original people and you know
I don't know details about the shooter
today in in Louisville
but all of these people who take this
[__] out you know these white males
these incels that that go up and shoot
people in Buffalo or or in any of these
other places are people that you know
didn't get the participation Award right
that weren't accepted they were rejected
by the world that the Republicans uh try
to try to instill on everyone right like
oh that's tough [__] [__] pick
yourself up by your bootstraps I don't
give a [__] I'm not going to show you
empathy I'm not going to care for you
I'm not gonna actually uh be curious
about uh uh what's going on in your life
to see hey maybe we can
maybe we can help you right but Hitler
is the original Maga incel shooter
and I I'm Gonna Stand by that I'm Gonna
Stand by that so do you want to you want
some evidence
um from don't take it from me take it
from Senator Ted Cruz from his official
government account you want some
evidence that uh Harlan Hitler there's
Harlan Hitler funded judges do you want
Evans yeah yeah I'm I have something to
say about this too so here's Ted Cruz
from his officials he's still up he said
honored to attend Jim hose swearing in
to the fifth Court Circuit Court excuse
me of appeals today
alongside Justice Clarence Thomas
and Judge Jerry Smith I am confident my
good friend Jim will be an extraordinary
appellate judge and a principal jurist
faithful to the law so here they are
swearing them in
guess where this is it it's in it's in
the Hitler [__] Library this is this
is in the mind conference yeah
um apparently
um this picture so apparently flight
records are showing that yes they all
flew out to Dallas to swear him in
in his funders Hitler mineconf Library
folks if you're doubting me I I know I
know you did people tend to do this
because they think I'm [__] crazy
Tony's just crazy [__] he just pulls
conspiracy theories out of nowhere when
he says [__] like
Harlan Hitler funded judges
folks there's three [__] judges
standing in this goddamn library of
Harlan Crowe swearing in federal judges
and Ted Cruz is a [__] sitting United
States Senator and you're wondering if
Harlan Hitler is funding judges get the
[__] out of here with that [__] of
course it is also I don't know of any
person that has been sworn in in a
private residence like this before
I don't know any judge I've never seen
any judge I mean typically uh if I'm not
mistaken and someone can fact check me
if they want to do a little research on
this one but I'm almost positive if not
100 certain
that when you're sworn in it's done in a
public area like in a public like uh
public setting not to say that it's
always like outside or whatever but like
you know in a in a in a a government
building or something that wouldn't be
the private residence of uh Hitler
simping billionaire who funds politics
and influences judges in their home
right someone's wanting to know who
nominated this this was back in 2018 so
you do the math on who [__] nominated
who nominated it was the Federal Society
who nominated this Trump sold out his
nominations to the federal Society I
wonder
who James Jim Jim ho yeah yeah yeah
Federal Society Circuit Judge right here
right here are you telling me are you
telling me that I knew that he was from
the federal Society because Heartland
Hitler funds the federal Society hangs
out with the people who [__] run the
federal Society at his [__] Hitler
Mansion or whatever the hell it is is
mineconf Library yes of course these are
Hitler Harlan Hitler funded judges
Harlan Hitler funded judges I'm going to
Tweet it to [__] Senator Ted Cruz
because I don't give a [__] yeah I don't
give a [__] there you go take and you
know what I find funny about this is
that all these Republicans are like oh
man the new judge that's proceeding over
Trump's uh Manhattan case this the hush
money payment case paid a total of 35 oh
my God whoa to who to well to act blue
Joe Biden what are you telling me are
you telling me that that judge funded
Joe Biden not Joe Biden funded him
because that's backwards
no that's the opposite direction with 35
yeah but when they accuse someone of
having political influence you have to
receive see when you receive the funds
you give payment for those funds that
you received which would mean that the
35 Joe Biden owes that judge in
Manhattan something I don't know what it
is
just one payment it was three payments
structuring political influence is that
what you're saying I'm I'm just saying
like the influence that he has on Joe
Biden and now 35. do you think you could
get Joe Biden give you a [__] for 35
I don't know I don't know I don't know
where you can get what would you ever
get what was normally really I don't
know I've never [__] so I have no
idea come on don't lie to us I'm telling
you the truth man never I'm saying never
no I've never paid for it I'd never pay
for a blowjo I never had to pay for a
blow job either but I'm just saying what
do you get for Joe Biden what would you
get for 35 bucks what do you think if
you're like hey man I gave you 35 hours
I want I want ice cream ice cream 35
bucks you probably get some like
presidential ice cream yeah [__] some
presidential type [__] so nice right
bougie right that's the kind of that's
that's the [__] you get for 35 bucks
yeah that's what you get for 35 bucks
okay I got you so just be an ice cream
buffet then yeah pretty much I mean
sprinkles and everything [__] you
know if you like whipped cream I was in
the Twitter space when they were saying
that [__] when they're like oh this
judge gave gave a 15 payment a 10
payment another ten dollar payment to
Joe Biden I'm like that's the opposite
of the direction of money and you're
talking about 35 bucks you dummies
because uh when they when they doxed me
online when they when all the trolls
dashed me they're like Tony gave to act
blue to Joe Biden and September
it was like four or five different
people that I gave in 2020 right right
and I'm like yeah so I'm I'm legally
allowed to give
and it's a up to 2500 hours um
to any [__] campaign that I won I can
I can do that legally it's my [__]
legal right it's my right as a Citizens
I can do that and I I obviously I'm a
[__] liberal so I'm gonna support
liberals that's what I'm gonna do and it
was after after the primary season so
they couldn't even be like oh well he's
been abiding simp all along no I I was I
was [__] against Trump in 2020 and I
I needed to make sure that Joe Biden had
a little extra scratch and I kind of
wanted my ice cream I'm not lying in one
of mine I mean if I gave money I would
expect ice cream but yeah the it doesn't
we're still waiting on my ice cream joke
joke where the [__] is my ice cream
where the [__] is my ice cream goddamn
the the ice cream River doesn't flow
that direction obviously well but you
look at them and like oh 35 he should
recuse himself oh really let's look at
Clarence Thomas man that guy's been
[__] what was it one trip or was it
all the trips that were five hundred
thousand dollars well see and that's
and that's manga is missing and and Ben
Shapiro misses with these gifts because
Harlan Hitler's um
and infatuation with with the leader of
Nazi Jeremy Adolf Hitler that's not what
it's about man what it's about is that
Clarence Thomas wasn't taking cash or
political contributions they were hiding
it as oh what's just a friend on a trip
with me and I'm staying I'm on a million
dollar yacht so he has to be at what am
I going to put him on my Lifeboat and
I'm on the I mean they're hiding all
this [__] through these through through
a way of of giving them these luxury
gifts it's not cash right it's not me
writing a check or the other judge for
Manhattan writing a check or seeing a
payment to act blue for 15 bucks that's
transparent that's actual transparent
[__] funding of Elections you dummies
and transparent of of [__] funding
political affiliation this guy is like
yeah hey hey Clarence this is Harlan
Hitler I'm gonna go on a trip to China
and here's what I want I'm we're going
to be on luxury [__] planes luxury
boats and I want you to be my guest
but here's the thing is that you know
this is going to cost a lot of money but
we're not gonna actually give you money
you're just gonna be along for the ride
and that's what they're claiming here
but all the while um this morning
there's more news from Jeannie Thomas
where she actually didn't disclose
income of course she didn't why would
she the same reason that Clarence Thomas
was like why do I need to disclose this
[__] even though he's broken I mean
that's the look there's there's an
ethical code that the Supreme Court has
to go by right
you said what there's an ethical code
apparently not yeah well apparently not
right but then there's also the idea
that uh I think it was after [__] what
is it nine it was after Watergate which
basically said like you you have to
disclose this stuff right if you have
these gifts and he's like oh I don't
have to disclose stuff if they're done
as personal right friends right because
I was just on the ride along and he was
taking these big yachts in these big
planes well was I supposed to do right
it was a group of people right I just
happened to be the person he was rhyming
a lot he was he was bribing a lot of
people at the same time okay
what do you want for me I was like a tan
gentle like attachment you know right
like I was just there because he said
hey two people dropped out you guys want
to come in and that's all it was I took
this trip to Indonesia I went on this
yacht I went in this Resort I went in
the jet I did this he [__] fed me did
this did this he said no no I wonder if
they had the bougie ice cream oh they
had the booze they were making images
way better than Biden's ice cream right
yeah I mean I mean look the the
sprinkles were made out of [__] gold
okay
do you think do you think it was like
gold leaf off of like a like an ancient
Hitler painting or something they like
look these are these are Hitler
sprinkles okay gold it was gold shaving
sprinkles that were from like uh it was
it from an actual gold brick right they
had the [__] Insignia of the of the
swastika on that Germany evil Nazi
Germany and then it's like oh would you
like some spring some gold shavings
would you like some swastika sprinkles
on you and then you know and then
Clarence and Jenny are like oh yeah we
would love some where you know like what
is it he goes oh just the best we you
know have to offer it's uh it's Nazi
gold and he's like
oh man so you think they used like a
gold grater then to get the the
sprinkles onto yeah I think that you
know like what like a uh
there yeah I would say probably some
sort of like a cheese grater type thing
but for gold right or like uh a mandolin
kind of thing like and it's definitely
vanilla ice cream though right yo yeah
yeah yeah
whoa whoa whoa whoa right but they're
like look only white ice cream only
white only white
but it's got to be I mean Gary says and
it's true
I wouldn't be surprised if I mean that's
where the gold I mean that's where they
[__] did they're you know and that's
something else I thought about too is
like you know Nazis they love to take
all these art these historical artifacts
right the these paintings and sometimes
they destroy them sometimes they kept
them because they're like they're gonna
be worth much more
but you know what paintings they never
kept hmm
Hitlers right
right they never thought like oh man you
know Hitler was never like hey we should
uh we should add these to the the the
the pile and they're like oh what is
this stupid [__] you know and he's like
you say that in Germany is that he's
saying I don't know probably
um
here's Patriot takes uh in 2011 Justice
Thomas filed amendments to claim 13
years of unreported income for Genie
Thomas dispute checking a box each year
indicating Genie Thomas had quote no
reportable non-investment income the
income came from the Heritage found whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa is this
the same Heritage Foundation that the
that the Harlan Hitler judges are
members of that is okay in Hillsdale
College if you don't know who Hillsdale
College is that's also a Nazi
organization
um wait but it's called College it would
be Nazi okay so 2011 top Justice Thomas
had to amend his filing
um after it was found out that 13 years
of unreported income was discovered in a
dispute oopsies we didn't report that my
bad that's the type of [__] where you're
like oh that's tax evasion you're not
reporting this stuff as an income that's
where the IRS would say hey guys uh you
either pay a fine or we take it to jail
hey and ban the IRS listen listen if
they can do it to Jeannie Thomas and
Clarence Thomas they can do it to us
okay if they can come after you they can
come in anyone and you know what I hope
they do come after anyone for breaking
the law
Harlan Hitler funded judges uh you've
seen it right here you've seen the proof
the uh the tweet that I showed you from
Ted Cruz that they flew down Harlan
Hitler funded judges and swarming in the
mine comp room of the Harlem Hitler
Library just outside the garden of
authoritarianism folks we're on top of
these [__] we didn't get to
even a fraction of the [__] news but
I tried I tried I'm sure that this story
yeah is oh this is not the end yeah
the rest of the I mean it's only Monday
this [__] broke at the end or like near
the end of the week last week and this
weekend was like oh here's a photo
here's this document here's this
document here's a photo I guarantee that
probably through this week we'll see how
long it lasts but how much money how
much money you think uh Ted Cruz took
from uh Harlem Hitler you think Ted Cruz
is is Harlan Hitler funded
you don't show up to a hitler-loving
Billionaire's house right if he's not
going to be your sugar daddy well could
be right I mean you're not going to show
up and come how many times have you been
to George soros's house that's all I'm
saying how many times good point that's
a good point how many times have you
been to Georgia maybe that's why we
don't get paid well that's maybe why we
don't receive our Soros checks we didn't
show up to his uh yeah yeah yeah to his
house and it's I don't know I mean like
but again you you look at these
Republicans you look at Ted Cruz you
look at all these other people man
they're all [__] it's all woven
together and now some of these threads
people are picking at and pulling this
[__] apart and being like hey wait this
person was here at this time and they
did this thing and they this other
person was there at this time and they
got a lot of money and they were giving
money to this thing that they're a part
of right and people are going to begin
to unravel
you know and think thank goodness for
the propublica you know the right wing
media is like oh the leftist propublica
well the leftist propublica seems to be
having accountability to the reporting
listen it's not leftist Undercover the
truth you dumb [__] yeah just
because it's truth and you don't like it
doesn't mean it's from the left it just
it's the [__] truth okay the truth
as Ben Shapiro would say facts don't
care about your feelings yeah
the fact is that the hitler-loving
Harlan Crow AKA Harlan Hitler dictator
simping billionaire is a [__] Nazi
whoa that's the fact that sorry that's
it sorry and we're gonna end right there
today on Harlan Hitler is a [__] Nazi
and anyone who he funds is a [__]
Nazi because if there's a if there's a
Nazi at the table eating dinner and then
there's 10 other people sitting at that
table eating dinner with that Nazi
you've got 11 [__] Nazis in your hand
and we're gonna keep our eyes on them
every single weekday noon Eastern 11
Central nine Pacific Monday through
Friday every single weekday for two pool
hours don't forget to subscribe here on
the Tony Michaels podcast download every
single episode on Apple's Spotify and
Google we're gonna play hide and seek
this week I'm gonna tell you we'll tell
you more about it tomorrow we'll tell
you more about hide and seek tomorrow
we're gonna play hide and seek on Gabe
Sanchez's YouTube channel you should go
over and subscribe to his YouTube
channel but also check out what was
thatshow.com there's a new episode a new
episode dropped this weekend yesterday
yeah two days ago and there's another
episode that I just covered on Trump
going to the UF FC fight in the utter
dude the guy looks like such like looks
like [__] he looks like such [__] looks
like [__] that's another one that's
coming out today so go to patreon.com I
am Gabe Sanchez while you're on patreon
check out my patreon page patreon.com
the Tony Michaels we're gonna have the
patreon party this Sunday two hours I'm
probably gonna be wasted for that so
don't forget maybe I'll send it yeah
yeah there you go
um follow us on Facebook at the Tony
Michaels and if you got an Amazon Prime
account uh link it to your Twitch
account give us that one free
subscription you get with the Amazon
Prime account also if you are linked to
your Twitch account with your Amazon
don't forget to go over and renew your
subscription every month you gotta go
every month and renew your subscription
so do that for us same time same place
tomorrow we're going to be banging at
these Nazis every [__] day including
tomorrow until then Surf's Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] them [__]
them
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn hadass Beacon